senior NBA writer of bleach report
joining us here on the program how are
you Howard
I was do a great risk thing so are you
okay so I mean James Harden the beard 32
straight games now of 30 points he could
not be more of a boldface name in the
NBA calling out an official by name how
does that sit in New York City and
League office do you think today Howard
it won't fit well no not coming from
James Harden as the reigning MVP not
coming from Chris Paul as a longtime
veteran decorated all-star and by the
way president of The Players Association
those are two people with a lot of
weight to throw around if they want to
in the fact that Chris Paul revealed
that he's had meetings between the
league and himself and Scott foster is
interesting on its own you know there
have been people around the league since
Chris Paul has been in this position who
have thought that he has used his
position as president of the Players
Union to his advantage or used it as
something to hold over people I've even
heard of him telling referees in the
midst of a game hey you know I've got
this this relationship with Adam silver
so he's not shy about using whatever
authority or weight he believes he has
now all that said I'm not saying he's in
the wrong necessarily I don't know I
don't know what the root of this you
know supposed beef is between him and
Scott foster or the fact that he thinks
that Scott Foster has a personal issue
with him which James Harden obviously
James Harden's echoing it because he's
heard it directly from his teammate
Chris Paul and I assume Chris Webber if
he's invoking that heard it directly
from Chris Paul as well what the root of
that is I don't know I think it's
dangerous to throw that out there the
rich I think for the player to throw out
there that there's that this is not
about you know a particular official or
about that official style but instead
it's somehow personal that kind of
poisons the well and and further James
Harden went went one step beyond that
not just poison the well basically
saying you can't referee our games you
can't have that players cannot be
dictating teams cannot be dictating
which officials rotate in and out of
their games and Scott foster has
been for years one of the highest rating
rated referees in the NBA you will see
him always deep the playoffs and the
finals and you know that if this team if
the Rockets are gonna be around deep
into the postseason they're gonna see
him multiple times and the last thing
you want to do I would think one is to
inflame that situation you know with the
referee himself and with the league
office but to to then create this haze
around every time Scott Foster referees
your game because now everyone's going
to be talking about it and writing about
it commenting on it and they're gonna
start to see every call he makes or
doesn't make through that prism that is
corrosive that is exactly why the league
has fines and a fine structure for
criticizing rest because they don't want
to get into a situation like this where
people start viewing everything through
this warped lens
Scott Foster was voted in in LA Times
poll of unnamed players the worst
referee in the league in 2016 so he has
that as well and he does have 25 years
in the league too though Howard I mean a
couple years ago and we saw a tech
extravaganza in the NBA the conversation
was all the vets had been cycled out and
retired and the new guys coming in
didn't have any relationships with the
players and is leading to a lot of
miscommunication and a lot of technical
fouls but Foster's been around a quarter
century I'm wondering do we have the
problem again of officiating in players
or this is just a one-off do you think
well I think it's something that
evidence flows rich I mean it's
something that never really goes away if
you think about it I mean last year was
this spike and I think frankly the spike
in Clair referee tensions last year I
think was a little overdone by all of us
in the media I don't think it was ever
as bad as it looked there were a few
high-profile cases involving
high-profile teams or some of the bigger
stars in the game so it got more
attention than usual but I don't think
it was necessarily any better or worse
of a year these things do have an flow
it sometimes does depend on the convey
the composition of the officiating staff
at any given time it sometimes it
depends on just the the generation of
players you know there was a time when
players you know made their complaint
you know and then went on their way and
now we've got the guys you know that at
least last season they were really not
letting it go and you know it's it's
frankly a fruitless pursuit I've never
seen a referee change a call based on a
player complaining that he got it wrong
because they can't they they can't take
back the whistle
so I you know I think that this case is
specific to one referee and one player
or team so I this is not necessarily a
Scott Foster issue I haven't heard the
rest of the league say the same that
it's all personal this is about Chris
Paul and Scott foster apparently to the
LA Times thing I just want to say real
quick you know it was a limited number
of players it's obviously not a full
toll all 450 players not something when
the players are asked about who's the
worst Ref they're going to go with the
guy that they don't like so skill wise
Scott foster raped out and you've got to
get reviewed to death by the league
office Scott foster still write that as
one of their top refs year in year out
so we know he's one of their best refs
no matter what the player poll might
have concluded but those guys are going
to vote we're going to offer a name
based more on whether they like a guy or
not or whether as Chris Paul and James
Harden allude to whether or not he's
willing to engage when you disagree with
them Howard back a bleacher report here
on the Rich Eisen sh all right let's
turn to the Lakers I mean that was a
must have they couldn't fall two games
under 500
and have a hope and their remaining
games one would think of getting too
deep into the top part of the conference
so they needed it they had to have it it
was against the team in Houston that is
in the playoffs as we speak
what do you think of the Lakers chances
of making the playoffs
Howard Beck little less confident in
that now than I would have said you know
before LeBron went down for the 17 game
stretch and they just kind of you know
cratered without him or certainly
drifted at a minimum I still think
they're in a good position to make it
though the teams that they're mostly
contending with for those last two spots
are the Clippers and the Kings the
Clippers who jettisons their best player
Tobias Harris at the trade deadline
still have a lot of good players by the
way but still jettisoned their best
player at the trade deadline and have
incentive to not make the playoffs
because they could keep the traffic and
the Kings who well are having a
breakthrough season that I think all of
us are really having a great time just
seeing it's fun to see the Kings good
again it's fun to you know Sacramento's
been through enough but it's a young
team I'm certainly not rooting for them
to miss but I will just say young teams
usually hit some some bumps in the road
at inopportune times if they faded it
wouldn't surprise me just because of the
composition of that team however they
also made a move to bolster themselves
for the stretch run by adding Harrison
Barnes at the deadline so that's a team
that clearly is trying to make it
I think the Lakers have two games left
against the Clippers one against the
kingdom so that will give them
opportunities to you know close the gap
and it's LeBron James I'm still not
going to bet against LeBron James I
think they make it interesting wouldn't
that be something else and then of
course it looks like they'd go take on
the Warriors who they only take on once
they do have a home and home against
Milwaukee which is a problem they do
have games against Phoenix Chicago and
the Knicks who we all know are tanking
for Zion who it was announced as out for
Saturday's game at Syracuse how did it
how does the NBA and we're hearing that
the Players Association is forwarding an
idea that the age minimum should be
lowered to 18 we're
work this all together here where we see
Zion shoo explode and the one-and-done
under attack right now in many ways
shapes inform how how do you think the
Zion shoo exploding played out in the
league office as well well I don't think
that that is necessarily an NBA issue at
the moment right now it underscores all
the reasons why the league and the
Players Association have been discussing
eliminating the age limit because it
does create some of these moral hazards
and puts guys in jeopardy now listen as
I am Williamson could have been wearing
a shoe that exploded while in an NBA
game in his rookie season two you know
accidents happen whether it's stepping
on somebody's foot when you land and
twisting your ankle just you know any
any number of mishaps that can happen of
course if that mishap happens while
you're already in the NBA with
guaranteed millions coming to you that
you know that underscores what the moral
hazard of the NCAA right but in Cameron
though and the reason why it did is
because the NBA has a rule that sends I
on to Cameron yeah unless he wants to
you know play in what some sort of G
League where he he can make a ton of
money in a shoe contract but nobody
watches him play and he makes a pittance
for a salary so yes that's the world
hazard I'm referring to rich I mean it
that's and so this is why the league in
the Union have been discussing this
clearly the league would rather not have
this be the structure anymore they have
gotten to a point where they believe
there there's a better way and with the
the G League growing within them now
three three teams shy of having a full
30 team complement it opens the door to
being able to say listen maybe we don't
need the age limit anymore because if we
draft guys in and they're not ready
every single team has a G League
affiliate to send them to so we can do
this the same way baseball does where
guys don't come straight to the league
but they're not there yet and the Union
and the league still have to figure out
what the structure is or the trade-offs
are or eliminating the limits and the
timeline you know and but part of it is
well two out Howard back here in terms
of just with the pro game just last
night watching the games seeing the
Kings and the Warriors slug it out
what a great game between the Celtics
and the box
you know the Sixers without embiid that
was a that was a fun game to see them go
it with Miami just for a night just for
one night it being about the game and
not about free agency that maybe just in
this this period of who makes the
playoffs and who's not we can return to
just watching the game in a way and then
I see the Lakers are at New Orleans
Saturday in the New Orleans in Los
Angeles Wednesday and next Friday
Anthony Davis is on the shop with LeBron
and we're gonna get this thing going
again don't you think yeah probably I
think I think it's kind of unavoidable
every time LeBron and Anthony Davis are
within you know 10 feet of each other
every glance every every you know thing
they might say why we pull up at the top
of the Jersey and whisper to each other
I just yeah it's gonna be a zoo it'll be
a circus but then the following Saturday
that the the the Celtics come to the
Lakers we got that going on I mean in in
Kyrie is abroad crock Tyrese Chaffin
about videos of him talking to Durant
during the all-star game you know and
I'm just wondering again what how you
feel about what I've been positing all
week that until somebody beats the
Warriors this is gonna be the main drama
while we all you know twiddle our thumbs
to see who we can actually knock off
Golden State in the seven-game series I
mean it's it's a it's a fair
juxtaposition rich I would I would
hazard to say though that I think if the
Warriors were not just dominant we would
still be talking about where Durant's
going to go and what Kyrie in Durant
might have been talking about in the
hallway and all the other stuff as Steve
Kerr said it like that NBA is a soap
opera and you just got to kind of you
know accept that and and you embrace it
or at least you know make peace with it
this is this is where we are and maybe
we've always been at this place but I
think it's just heightened in the arrow
that we're in with superstar free agency
and superstar movement being at an all
I'm high with social media amplifying
absolutely everything that is said done
implied it's that's just where we are as
a you know of sports media sports fans
the support itself and everybody feeds
into it including the players your aunt
can chief
Tyree can shape they feed into this by
you know in Grant's case going year to
year on his contracts and leaving it
open-ended and in kairi's taste having
already forced one trade having been you
know committal and then non-committal
about staying with the Celtics I mean
that's we know what we a wall wouldn't
be speculating about what may or may not
have been said in a video in a hallway
with no audio if it weren't for what
these guys have been doing and saying
themselves so it's you know again it's
just where we are and the Warriors being
dominant certainly does you know I think
probably push us toward finding other
things to fill the time to discuss about
the league Howard thanks so much
appreciate it
always a pleasure trip think you got a
tad Howard back bleach report also the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience